Oh
hey guys there's nobody here right now
it's just me but if you want to hang out
for a little bit and see how I make
props for nostalgia critic episodes
stick around and see how I do it okay
so generally how this works is about
three or four days before we shoot Doug
will send out the scripts and he'll send
me a list of all the props and stuff he
needs for the episode and depending on
all the other things I have it going on
I may only have a day or two to actually
find or build the things that are in the
episode so let's take a look at this
week's episode plate so first item on
the list is a blade cast and for Malcolm
let's see number two sword four blade
all right to desk plates one that reads
Marvel and one that reads DC pills for
Tamra but not real ones obviously pencil
drawing of comic book pages that look
like they're being drawn an artist
disabled so let's see alright so I'll
have to draw some comic book type stuff
so that'll be cool
two suits for myself which means that
I'll probably be in this episode at
least twice a printed contract and I
could say anything that should be enough
ten magazines and on the back of one of
the magazines a full-page color ad for
headache medication that's called
Captain America Civil War with the quote
that says everybody loves it yeah things
I really have to build or make or find
are the blade costume the blade sword
the desk plates and the drawing of the
comic book pages thing alright well
first off
I'll have to take a look at our wardrobe
see what I can use based on the stuff
that we already have I'm sure I have
some kind of a black vest that I can
doctor up kind of make it look like
blades best we have a black leather
trench coat I know and sunglasses and
stuff like that so that should be pretty
easy I might just have to cut out some
foam add some pieces to make it look
like it the blade sword I don't have
anything in my collection that looks
blade sword ish I used to I don't have
it anymore so probably to build
something from scratch but I only have a
date so we're gonna use materials I have
in the shop to kind of doctor up
something that looks enough like blade
sword to get through the joke which is
always part of the consideration when
building anything for the study critic
episodes is how much screen time is this
actually gonna have is it just have to
look good enough to tell the joke that
Doug wants to tell or is it going to be
something that's featured throughout the
entire review in which case it has to
look good and hold up to you know a full
day or two of shooting so in this case
perusing through the script it looks
like it's gonna be a really quick joke
you're gonna you're not gonna see bleed
a lot and the sword is only seen very
briefly very quick so it doesn't have to
look movie accurate again it just has to
look enough like blade swords do you
know what it is right so let's go get
all that things to do today
that might work
okay so I have the best and some craft
foam and the craft foam I'll just cut
out like the chest pieces and attach
them I don't want to do it permanently
fortunately there's a lot of velcro on
there so I'll probably just put velcro
on the back and velcro it right to the
piece and then I've got some of these
buckles that I will just put some
aluminum tape on here cover it give you
that reflective look I'll be here in
here or something and yeah that should
look pretty blade is there we can start
working on the sword and thank you to
the drawings
all right so this is it pretty easy I
said there's velcro down the craft foam
kind of chest plates because there was
already velcro on the vest itself and
then some of the aluminum tape over the
buckles and then the buckles are just
held on there just loop through with a
piece of leftover strap and some
electrical tape so they're not
permanently on there take them off slide
them out
I don't want alter the best in a way
that we can't use it again for something
else it's only gonna be on screen for a
few minutes so again just by the look
you know Malcolm the costume and stuff
like that you'll know exactly he's
supposed to be right off the bat doesn't
look super movie accurate but it looks
good enough for the joke for the sword
has to be lightweight we have to build
it pretty quickly it has to be
lightweight and not dangerous
I guess because we're gonna be I think
dropping it into Tamara's lap for the
gag so yeah it has to be black materials
look like the sword but it's only on be
on screen very briefly so it doesn't
have to be movie accurate I'm gonna see
what we have in the shop most likely
it's made built out of PVC pieces maybe
a piece of aluminum or plastic or
something that I have lying around I
don't want to use one of my real swords
because danger I don't know
all right so I get a hunk of PVC and a
little coupler and I probably find
another coupler and piece of this weird
tubing I'm gonna cut that off cut this
down spray paint black put on the the
ribbing and you need to find a blade but
I'm thinking I know we've got some cheap
swords up on the shelf somewhere that
could probably snag the blade off of
some cheap plastic costume swords and
yeah just steal one of those and pop it
on there let's go see all right so I
decided to go with this one it's to my
knowledge not being used for anything
else or anything the future so I'm just
a little cheap costume I'm a Halloween
store sword so now we'll just go through
the process of carefully removing the
handle from the blade
alright so that was actually way easier
than I thought it was gonna be I didn't
I mean that the piece on the blade
actually kind of fits perfectly into the
PVC pipe so I didn't have to do anything
major to assemble it all of it is just
literally popped together I got a little
bit of tape around the piece of ribbed
hose whatever to kind of keep it in
place but other than that that's it you
know it's a it's a close enough mock-up
of blade sword I think for what the
purposes we need so yeah that's it
sometimes it's that easy
alright well Rob actually popped in for
a little bit today so he actually made
the name plates for the Marvel and DC
that we needed out of some scrap wood
and in foam and stuff letting some tape
and everything that we had lying around
so yeah that's it those are done thanks
Rob alright so basically for the last
piece I just have to create a comic book
page like an artist is currently working
on so I actually happen to have some
comic book drawing boards or whatever
I'm just gonna sketch something that
looks somewhat comic book page II I
actually have no idea what I'm gonna do
I did a couple of quick sketches
alright cool let's see what happens
alright well that about does it for
today I hope you guys enjoyed this
little behind-the-scenes of kind of the
prop building and costume making process
of the nostalgic right
yeah if you guys enjoy them hopefully
I'll do more all right take care